i feel like not enough people know about  international women's day i remember i  asked one guy if he knew what iwd is and  he said yeah can you believe george bush  lied about them being in iraq  what are you talking about  according to wikipedia international  women's day is only an official holiday  in 26 countries and wait for it the u.s  is not one of them that's right  essentially it's the difference between  how i'm treated on this show and how i'm  treated when i try to get a drink at a  bar what  lily you don't have to do this to  yourself you really don't you had a good  thing going you had a good life do you  know why international women's day isn't  an official holiday in the u.s because  it's stupid  why would we have a holiday to celebrate  women yeah celebrate certain women if  you want to be celebrated go out and do  something to be celebrated for  tell a funny joke lily  that'd be an achievement